achtung windallee hier werden gäste und
pool möbel kräftig durchgewirbelt
privataufnahmen aus einem luxus hotel in
las vegas zeigen wie eine mini windhose
an einem pool tische und stühle durch
die luft fliegen lässt in setzt springen
und schreien die gäste auf doch schnell
wieder sturm gekommen war ist er auch
schon wieder vorbei lokalen
medienberichten zufolge werden mehrere
menschen leicht verletzt
momente später ist alles wieder ruhig
und es scheint als wäre nichts gewesen
aufgrund der größe und der
wetterbedingungen sprechen
wetterexperten von einem staub teufel er
dauert nur wenige minuten und bildet
sich vor allem bei klarem wetter
oben erwärmung und ein leichter wind
können für so einen staub teufel sorgen